hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
Android is one of Google's most
successful products in recent years it's
been very very popular lately but there
are a lot of things that people don't
know about it and it hasn't always been
a very popular and successful product so
without any further ado here are five
true facts about Android number five is
androids
origins a lot of people may think that
Android is Google's baby a lot of people
truly believe that but now Android is
adopted similar to a lot of existing
Google products Android was picked up as
a start-up earlier so originally in 2003
it was being produced any basically
developed by a company called Android
Inc in Palo Alto California and the head
or founder of that company was Andy
Rubin so you can see where that name
came from they were working on it and
developing it sensed from about 2003 to
2007 and then the original iPhone came
out in 2007 and Google decided hey
alright we're going to take this and
bring it to the next level
they bought Android for 50 million
dollars they hired Andy and I started
developing it into what it is today
number four is that Android almost
didn't happen like we said it was
originally funded for around 50 million
dollars when Google first bought it but
it almost immediately ran out of that
initial funding and it was in 2003 to
2007 so we don't really have a lot of
information about that on the web but
from what we know it almost immediately
ran out and it was basically rock bottom
and it started off very hot and then
very quickly was a really cold project
then was bailed out by an investment of
a few thousand dollars by Android or
rank one of androids founders originally
Steve Pearlman so it originally was
really hot then met really really cold
and then moved back up to a higher level
project as it was bailed out with some
financial problem Microsoft Scot Horan
who was at the time the head of Windows
Mobile's marketing team said to Engadget
after Android was released that he
didn't understand the impact Android
would have so you can see that it
started off as a very underrated project
it would probably be in an underrated
projects video if I did one but it was
an underrated project and you can see
exactly how far it's come today number
three is that more men than women
use Android like a lot more now I did
there is an exception to there are a
couple of exceptions to the rule
I reviewed the Samsung Galaxy Note 2 not
too long ago the link will be down below
the like button on this video but
basically for some reason that phone is
really popular with the ladies I think
it's a purse thing but I don't actually
know but for the most part actually 73%
of Android users as of the end of 2012
are men leaving 27% as woman now I don't
know how accurate that number is today
because it's been a few months since
then Android is still growing in
popularity so more people are using it
but there are a lot of interesting facts
about androids demographic also for
example Android users are on average
pretty young mostly between the 18 to 44
year old range and 60% at the end of
2012 were under the age of 34 so Android
has a lot of young men in its audience
so obviously a lot of the people who
watch my videos are also young men so I
can kind of understand where that
demographic comes from but yeah there is
a pretty interesting demographic for
Android phone users number two is that
Andy the Android mascot was not exactly
an original creation all you guys might
already know this but the first draft of
the robot was actually lifted from a
1990 atari lynx video game console game
called gauntlet the third encounter the
character's name was Android and it had
24 speed 7 strength and 9 missiles
whatever that means for us in today's
world we can probably figure that out
but in the end you can see it looks very
very similar to the original game
character the way it looks today down to
like the line around where the mouth is
separating the head and the antenna
everything looks similar but if you're a
small game creator back in the 1990's
especially when that game wasn't that
popular you're not going to sue Google I
mean it's Google so they got away with
it but that's why the Android logo looks
the way it does today and number one
Android in space is an actual thing in
2010 a British firm launched a Nexus One
into orbit as basically the brains of
the satellite where it runs scientific
experiments and collects data and it's
still there satellite has a name it's
called strand one but that's an acronym
and it actually stands for survey
training research and nano satellite
demonstrator according to the firm that
is in charge of this whole deal SST
the Nexus one that is part of the
satellite will be running apps that
collect scientific data we'll take
pictures of the earth using its 5
megapixel camera stable-yard
back then and it will also actually be
able to detect when the temperature is
getting too low and it will just ramp up
the CPU and run some intensive apps to
get the battery temperature back up
because you have to prevent the battery
from freezing so it actually knows when
it should be running apps that are
really hardcore to keep the battery
temperature up and that's actually
pretty neat to be honest along with its
serious purposes strand is said to have
an app on board that will run called
scream in space which as you can imagine
will emit a noise and basically test the
hole in space no one can hear you scream
theory and their hope working with that
experiment there's a whole bunch of neat
stuff it's doing again I'll leave some
links below to check out what you want
to learn about that but to be honest uh
there are no competing iphone satellites
yet but supposedly there's some problems
with Apple maps either way the fact that
that thing is still up there and is
doing well is pretty cool and that's
basically yeah those are some neat facts
about Android in a way that's been it
some honorable mentions I guess would go
to the fact that these things have names
the Android versions have names starting
from a all the way to the current letter
of the alphabet they've all been desert
names so if you've noticed Astro bender
cupcake donut Eclair Froyo gingerbread
honeycomb Ice Cream Sandwich jelly bean
and probably key lime pie and lemon cake
and a whole bunch of others as we get
all the way through the alphabet I don't
know what X is going to be I don't know
what Z is gonna be but it'll be fun to
see what Android names these things
anyway that's a quick video guys just
wanted to give you guys some fun facts
about Android if you did enjoy this
video and you want to see some other
videos similar to it I'll have a
playlist down below with my other top 5s
and if you want to subscribe you'll be
able to see all the other videos I put
out so there you go thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you guys in the night
Aysen
you